she laughed at me Shane numb humiliation
I didn't tell anyone for six years
guilty denial helpless and I got a call
from the detective he was like so were
you raped or did he just kind of like
beat you up during sex
[Music]
nowadays I find it pretty easy to talk
about my assault I don't know if that's
because I've processed it so well or I
just really haven't processed it very
well at a halt and I just like can't
feel those emotions two dudes grab me by
the shoulders held me in place against a
counter top Wow she the older woman
proceeded to just peel off my clothing
and touched me wherever she felt like it
she groped me she laughed at me he
grabbed me he groped me he grabbed my
crotch multiple times I wasn't sure what
was happening and he looked at me and he
said what's wrong and I said something
doesn't feel right and he goes nothing's
happening nothing's wrong things kept
getting rougher and rougher he grabbed
me really forcefully by the throat and I
couldn't breathe he hit me really hard
across the face and he was just like
huge and muscley and holding me down
just felt like moisture coming down my
face and I was like oh you're you're
crying
there's so many people who are survivors
of some sort of rape or sexual assault
so what we do is tend to shut down
survivors stories hearing people's
responses to it made me feel like I
couldn't trust my own intuition the most
damaging thing I heard was by talking
about it you're giving him more power he
told me I'm sorry you felt you were
raped I felt not heard
I felt assaulted again
a culture that we learn to treat people
like things and you don't treat people
like things when I told my best friend
and she was silent that was still a very
clear lab response that I was making her
uncomfortable and I should stop talking
sexual violence is prevalent at a
massive level in this country we tend to
not believe people because sometimes
it's too much and then other times
because people have a vested interest in
not talking about rape and not talking
about sexual violence what ends up
happening is incredible damage to people
their sense of self their sense of trust
in others I want people all genders
always talking about consents not taking
it for granted that somebody wants to do
something because you hope that they
want to do something reaching for
empathy the sense of I'm worthwhile I'm
valuable and so I should negotiate on my
behalf and people respecting that you
get to choose even if that disappoints
me even if I don't like it but that you
still respect somebody's sovereignty
sexuality can be edgy and it can be
exciting and it can have an intensity to
it but that's not rape and that's not
violence those are other things that are
not negotiated that are not consensual I
want people to find pleasure in their
daily lives with one another and with
themselves
I believe pleasure and connection are
the antidote to trauma and rape culture
oh we're stronger together we love you
thicket animals don't let this silence
you I feel I feel held even though I've
never met these people we believe you
speak on it well it does not define you
be gentle with yourself this makes me
feel like there are people to listen
even if you don't know if they're right
there being a male survivor I very
rarely am permitted to talk about it
without feeling like I'm going to make
some be uncomfortable for me it kind of
makes me think about the power of
empathy there's such fear around
vulnerability you know I think like
what's the worst that could happen if
you tells a friend that you know who's a
survivor like hey just checking in are
you okay just want you to know that I
support you even if you do have your
friend a friend who's like really strong
like to check in on them you know
especially if you're strong cuz I feel
like sometimes the strong person gets
like overlooked it never hurts to let
someone know that they're not alone yeah
take care of yourself
yeah it's okay to set boundaries it's
okay to say no it's okay to take out
space but the noise
[Laughter]
[Music]